bonjour à tous et ravi de vous retrouver
sur Public Sénat tout au long du mois de
septembre je vous propose de revoir les
temps forts de la séance et des
auditions lors de la dernière session
parlementaire car au mois de septembre
et bien les sénateurs sont encore
absents du Palais du Luxembourg car ils
sont en campagne et ils préparent
activement les élections sén orial qui
se tiendront le 28 septembre et qui
permettront de renouveler la moitié de
la Haute Assemblée retour ce matin à
l'audition de Laurent Fabius qui avait
été entendu le 6 mai dernier par les
commissions du développement durable et
des affaires économiques sur la
conférence de Paris 2015 sur le climat
une conférence qui devrait permettre
d'arriver enfin à un accord un nouvel
accord universel sur le climat
d'ailleurs à l'occasion de cette
audition Laurent Fabius le ministre des
affaires étrangère avait indiqué combien
il était essentiel d'arriver à un accord
ambitieux avec de réels engagements en
matière de réduction des gaz à effet de
serre rappelons que cette 21e édition
sera d'ailleurs placée sous le signe de
l'exemplarité gouvernementale et qu'elle
a pour objectif de réduire au maximum
l'impact environnemental d'une telle
réunion retour tout de suite donc à
cette audition qui s'est tenue le 6 mai
dernier au Sénat bonjour à tous mes
chers collègues bonjour monsieur le
ministre bienvenue au Sénat
donc ben je suis très heureux
sincèrement avec mon collègue donc VI
président de la commission des affaires
étrangères et les membres de cette
commission et les membres de la
commission de développement durable de
vous accueillir donc pour vous entendre
sur la préparation du de la conférence
de Paris 2015 sur le climat alors avant
cela je voulais simplement vous dire que
notre commission du durable et la plus
jeune commission permanente du Sénat
elle a à peine 2 ans 2 ans un peu plus
de 2 ans d'existence mais dès sa
création elle s'est beaucoup intéressé
bien sûr à cette problématique vous
l'imaginez et nous avons d'ailleurs un
groupe qui s'est un petit peu spécialisé
dans les différents sommets qui ont eu
lieu et nous avons après le Sommet de
Copenhague participé au sommet de Rio où
d'ailleurs nous avons assisté une
conférence du président François
Hollande et de vous-même et nous avons
évidemment été un petit peu déçus mais
ça nous en parlerons tout à l'heure
alors je voudrais en profiter pour vous
dire que le le Sénat donc s'est
intéressé déjà depuis très longtemps
donc à cette problématique puisque il
faut le rappeler c'est en 2000 que euh
Paul vergess a créé l'observatoire
national sur les effets du réchauffement
climatique la fameuse onerque qui
d'ailleurs donc en relation avec tout ce
qu'a pu produire le GC a fourni des
documents très intéressants qui ont
commencé à essayer d'évaluer ce que
coûterait si nous ne faisons rien ceait
champ climatique et inversement ce que
pourrait coûter une action si nous
commencions assez tôt dans une forme de
prise de conscience et d'action alors le
président de la République et vous-même
donc avez fixé donc comme priorité pour
ce sommet et pour donc votre ministère
bien sûr non seulement évidemment de de
l'organiser mais bien sûr de le réussir
et bien sûr nous sommes tous derrière
vous pour essayer de contribuer donc à
cette réussite et c'est pour cela que
nous avons créé un groupe de travail
pour suivre donc ce sommet alors bien
sûr euh ce que nous souhaiterions
aujourd'hui c'est bien sûr essayer de
vous entendre sur le la préparation à
quel stade amist-on euh comment
avez-vous mobilisé vos services et notre
réseau de la diplomatie donc de cette
perspective quelles sont selon vous
aujourd'hui les perspectives de parvenir
un accord ambitieux lors de cette
conférence et enfin qu'attendez-vous du
Sénat euh et des sénateurs pour se tenir
votre démarche et celle de la diplomatie
française voilà monsieur le ministre
nous avons donc devant nous 1 heure 1
he15
si vous voulez bien
donc faire ce point et ensuite vous
verrez les questions vont se déchaîner
et nous esserons bien sûr d'y répondre
voilà Monsieur le ministreci beaucoupés
collègue veut dire de mot ah je peux
faire oui le mot d'accueil puisque le la
commission des affaires étrangères
accueille son ministre en quelque sorte
mais c'est vrai que le sujet euh qui
nous occupe aujourd'hui relève largement
de la Commission de développement local
c'est vrai que l'actualité est plus
portée en matière d'affaires étrangères
du côté de l'Ukraine
ou ou ou du Sahel ou de Centre-Afrique
mais je constate pour paraphraser
quelqu'un qui fut célèbre et qui l'est
toujours que la maison brûle mais que
vous ne regardez pas ailleurs voilà en
la circonstance ce long
processus sur le changement climatique
enclenché déjà depuis fort longtemps
peut vivre une étape des décisive
l'année prochaine à Paris nous
souhaitons naturellement que ça soit le
cas merci beaucoup monessieurs les
présidents ben mesdames messieurs des
sénateurs chers amis d'abord je vous
remercier de de m'accueillir aujourd'hui
dans cette maison que je connais et que
j'apprécie pour
évoquer un sujet extrêmement important
d'ordinaire quand je viens
devant vos commissions c'est pour parler
en général de politique étrangère mais
cette fois-ci c'est évidemment pour
parler de la 21e conférence des partis à
la Convention 4 des Nations Unies sur
les changements climatiques c'est son
nom complet
mais dans notre jargon
commun nous l'appelons la COP 21
ou aussi et je pense que c'est une
acception que vous ferez vôtre Paris
climat 2015 puisque
cela se fera chez nous
euh je ferai donc quelques remarques
introductives et ensuite bien sûr je
suis à votre entière disposition sachant
que les uns et les autres vous êtes des
spécialistes de ces questions d'abord
sur le degré d'urgence et sur
l'opportunité
d'agir les causes les manifestations bon
les conséquences
euh sont bien connu de vous dans les
dernières publications du GC il n'y a
absolument aucune ambiguïé euh le
changement climatique est sans précédent
et l'influence des activités humaines
est incontestable d'ailleurs c'est une
remarque que je me permets de faire en
passant et que le vice-président algor
m'a fait lorsque nous trouvions ensemble
dans une réunion au début du mois de
janvier si l'on se rapporte à l'état
d'esprit euh qui existait dans l'opinion
publique y compris dit éclairé il y a
seulement de ou 3 ans il y a un
changement considérable car quasiment
plus personne ne conteste d'une part la
gravité du phénomène et d'autre part son
origine humaine alors que vous vous
rappelez je ne citerai pas de nom que
dans les différents continents et la
France fait partie d'un de ces
continents euh il y a encore peu de
temps ces phénomènes étaient contestés
ils ne le sont plus contenu à la fois de
la profondeur des problèmes et de la
qualité des analyses qui ont été menées
par les scientifique toutes les données
statistiques sont sans équivoque et bien
au-delà de la marge d'erreur que
d'ordinaire les scientifiques retiennent
quels sont les risques je vais pas les
énumérer tous mais je donnerai juste
quelques exemples puisque je crois qu'en
plus la presse nous fait l'amitié d'être
là le volume total des glaciers pourrait
être réduit de moitié voire de 80 %
d'ici à 2100 si rien n'est fait
l'augmentation du niveau de la mer
pourrait bouleverser nos côtes puisque
la mer pourrait monter de plus de 50 cm
d'ici la fin du siècle et jusqu'à près
d'un M selon les hypothèses les plus
pessimistes ceci je ne sais pas s'il
faut dire le conditionnel ou le futur
entraînerait des risque d'érosion et
d'inondation de plus en plus fréquent
sur les côtes où vit la majorité de la
population
mondiale ce qui
signifie évidemment les choses ne sont
pas aussi mécaniques mais il faut donner
des traductions
concrètes d'un kerque partiellement sous
l'eau la Méditerranée arrivant jusqu'à
Arles et et Rotterdam devenu une île
ceci n'est plus de la science-fiction
mais une hypothèse malheureusement
possible à la fin de ce siècle si rien
de suffisant n'est fait d'autre part les
changements climatique entraîneront
aussi des risques accrus sur le secteur
agricole qui pourrait perturber la
sécurité alimentaire mondiale notamment
les populations les plus vulnérables que
deviendrai les 40 % de la population
mondiale qui de l'agriculture si
beaucoup de récoltes sont amputées
d'un/art à cause à la fois de la chaleur
et du manque d'eau
euh tout cela est fort bien résumé dans
les trois rapports qui ont déjà été
publiés par le GC et je voudrais faire
quelques observations à la lecture des
dernières conclusions du 5e rapport du
JEC qui nous apporte un diagnostic
scientifique clair et un état des lieux
préoccupant sur les possibles impacts
en particulier la baisse des rendements
agricoles l'élévation du niveau d' mer
et la création de nouvelles poches
massive de
pauvreté d'ailleurs j'en tire une
conséquence qui va peut-être vous
paraître superficielle mais qui ne l'est
pas car les mots sont toujours
importants le mot de changement
climatique qui est souvent utilisé me
paraît beaucoup trop
neutre car après tout sans faire
référence à tel ou tel slogan politique
le ch ement est souvent perçu comme
positif et ce terme changement
climatique ne rend pas compte de la
gravité des risques je vis faire évoquer
pour ma part non plus le réchauffement
car scientifiquement ce n'est pas exact
les phénomènes à l'œuvre se traduiront
parfois par des réchauffements parfois
par des refroisissements le plus souvent
par des bouleversements et pour toute
une partie de la population y compris la
population
française évoquer la perspective d'un
réchauffement n'est pas après tout
nécessairement dramatique chacun au nord
de la Loire s'imaginant pouvoir vivre
sur la Côte d'Azur mais il s'agit
devenons sérieux de nouveau pas du tout
de ça il s'agit d'un dérèglement
climatique en anglais climate
disruption qui exprime bien ce qui est
en jeu c'est-à-dire la capacité de
l'espèce humaine à se nourrir à se
développer à vivre décemment et même à
survivre c'est de cela qu'il s'agit donc
c'est pas simplement un changement
climatique et certains commencent même à
parler en anglais la présidente de la
convention climat parle de Global weness
c'est-à-dire d'étrangeté globale c'est
un phénomène de bizarrerie globale si
nous restons inactifs nous allons léguer
à nos enfants un monde en rupture avec
celui que nous avons connu dangereux et
évidemment
extrêmement difficile à vivre le 3ème
volet du rapport du JEC j'ai dit
quelques conclusions que je tirais de
ces travaux qui été publiés il y a peu
de semaines montre à la fois la gravité
de ces conséquences du phénomène
lui-même et qu'il est encore temps
d'agir je prends comme exemple une des
principales préconisation du
rapport un triplement voire un
cadruplement de la production d'énergie
sobre en
carbone certains pourrai y voir un mal
nécessaire mais dans un monde où les
coûts de ces sources d'énergie notamment
les renouvelables évoluent rapidement où
les conséquences des énergies fossiles
sur la santé sont de plus en plus clair
où l'innovation bacarbone commence à
réconcilier écologie économie je vois et
c'est une ligne directrice que nous
allons essayer de suivre dans sa
conférence de Paris j'y vois aussi une
chance à saisir c'est évidment une
contrainte redoutable mais il y a aussi
une chance à
saisir un deuxième point sur lequel je
voudrais faire quelques remarques c'est
sur l'utilité la forme que pourrait
prendre l'accord climatique auquel nous
aspirons beaucoup de pays et de régions
commence à saisir à la fois la
contrainte et la chance d'ailleurs vous
savez peut-être que aussi bien en
chinois contemporain qu'en grec ancien
c'est le même mot qui signifie le risque
et la chance
en chinois je ne sais pas en grec ça
s'appelle kindindunos c'est le souvenir
que j'ai de ma fréquentation qui n'a pas
laissé de trace apparente de tucidide de
de grands émetteurs mais aussi de plus
petits pays voi aujourd'hui dans
l'économie sobre en carbone une voie
alternative de développement et la Chine
qui n'est pas la moins concernée au
contraire a fait de ce qu'elle appelle
la civilisation écologique un de ses
objectifs explicites et il est devenu le
premier marché mondial pour les énergies
renouvelables aux États-Unis le plan
d'action du président Obama et on m'a
indiqué que président Obama devait
s'exprimer aujourd'hui je ne sais pas
s'il va le faire sur cette question a
envoyé un signal fort vers les acteurs
locaux et privés le Brésil je cite
quelques pays parement important est en
voie de tenir son objectif de 80 % de
réduction de la déforestation entre 2005
et 2020 l'Islande le Costa Rica de
petites villes îes vulnérables comme les
Maldives se sont engagés sur la voie de
la neutralité carbone ce sont là
quelques exemples parmi beaucoup
d'autres mais au total déjà près d'une
centaine de pays ont pris des
engagements de réduction de leurs
émissions de gaz à effet de serre ces
engagements sont volontaires en dehors
du protocole de Kyoto mais il pose et
c'est intéressant des jalons pour aller
plus loin collectivement l'enjeu d'un
accord à Paris d'un accord universel
et de fournir un cadre de mettre en
place des outils pour agir ensemble
mieux et plus vite et notamment parce
que c'est un point essentiel dans les
négociations d'aider les pays en
développement à s'adapter à s'engager
sur la voie d'un développement durable
par les transferts de technologie et la
mise en place de financement notamment à
travers le fond vert l'objectif pour
Paris 2015 tel qu'il a été fixé à Duban
il y a 2 ans est clair il doit s'agir
d'un accord appli cble à tous
juridiquement contraignant et comportant
des engagements de réduction d'émissions
compatible dans la durée avec un
réchauffement maximal de 2 degrés voilà
la commande générale ce sera si nous y
parvenons une première dans l'histoire
des négociations climatiques car
n'oublions pas que le protocole de Kyoto
est certes contraignant mais qui
concerne aujourd'hui à peine plus de 15
% des émissions mondiales
et les engagements volontaires de
copenhag et de Cancun concernent un
nombre important de pays mais il n'y a
pas de force juridique ce qui évidemment
les fragilise depuis Durban nous
commençons à forger une vision
collective de ce à quoi pourrait
ressembler un accord utile premièrement
cet accord serait d'abord constitué d'un
cadre robuste de règles et de mécanismes
pour garantir la transparence sur sa
mise en œuvre c'est-à-dire garantir que
les engagements de Paris ne seront pas
des paroles en l'air et permettre un
renforcement une évolution dans le temps
des engagements nationaux deuxièmement à
côté de ce socle commun viendrait
s'ajouter les engagements de réduction
d'émissions déterminé nationalement il
nous semble que la flexibilité devrait
être une caractéristique clé qu'est-ce
que je vous dire nous n'agissons pas
pour la conclusion d'un accord parfait
sur papier et qui serait obsolète après
sa signature il faut que cet accord
puisse accueillir les engagements
successifs sans que l'on doive
renégocier l'ensemble car il y a un
suivi dans le temps à opérer
troisièmement enfin Paris doit être le
moment de cristallisation d'initiative
de partenariat d'engagement des
différents acteurs et par différents
acteurs il y a bien sûr les États mais
aussi les collectivités locales les
entreprises les ONG les fonds
d'investissement m bout à bout ces
initiatives montreront que l'action est
lancée
que la lutte contre le dérèglement
climatique est non seulement possible
mais souhaitable pour apporter à nos
société et nos économies à la fois
soutenabilité croissance et bien-être
dans ce cadre que je drresse à grande
guide car il serait contradictoire de
vouloir jouer le rôle normal de la
présidence et en même temps de dire
voilà exactement où l'on va et je ne ve
voir qu'une tête il y a une fonction de
synthèse à opérer qui doit être distinct
c'est un point très important de la
contribution
de la France bien sûr la France préside
mais la France est aussi une partie
prenante et il ne faut pas confondre les
deux au risque évidemment de poser un
certain problème la stratégie française
quelle peut-être quel doit être notre
rôle en tant que pays haute dans la
conclusion souhaitable de cet accord la
première priorité c'est l'exemplarité
nationale en ce début d'année il y a eu
la contribution climat énergie qui est
un pas la loi sur la transition
énergétique qui va vous être soumise
avant l'été je crois dans le calendrier
parlementaire devra nous mener plus loin
vous aurez vous un rôle essentiel dans
la construction et l'adoption de cette
loi qui doit être aussi ambitieuse que
possible car mieux nous agirons
nous-mêmes plus nous serons légitimes à
encourager d'autres à s'engager la
ministre de l'écologie et du
développement durable qui est
responsable pour la partie française
même si c'est moi-même qui qui préside
la conférence euh évidemment
euh mènera ce travail pour devenir ce
qu'elle appelle j'espère que ce sera le
cas la première puissance écologique
d'Europe et nous devons tendre vers cela
à la fois à cause d' trôre exemplaire et
parce que la compétitivité de la France
est en jeu mais au-delà de la France
c'est l'Europe dans son ensemble qui
doit montrer ce qu'est l'exemple et euh
il faut à cet égard souligner que c'est
sur la base d'une certaine transition
écologique que l'Europe a construit
durant plusieurs années un leadership
qui est assuré au sein des négociations
climatiques internationales et s'il n'y
avait pas ce leadership nous ne
pourrions même pas parler de
l'éventualité d'un accord mondial en
2015 nous devons jouer ce rôle
d'entraînement jusqu'à Paris et au-delà
et concrètement ça veut dire que
malheureusement nous n'avons pas pu au
mois de mars aboutir à une décision
formelle de l'Union européenne alors que
la Commission avait fait des
propositions intéressantes la France
souhaite très vivement que nous
parvenions à une conclusion précise au
maximum au mois de mai ou juin car
passer ce délai et contenu en plus du
remplacement de la commission qui va
faire que des difficultés inévitables
vont être encourues nous risquerion en
tant qu'Européen de ne pas pouvoir
donner des indications aux autres si
nous ne sommes pas capable nous-même de
prendre des décisions ce qui veut dire
que dans notre stratégie diplomatique
vous mvez interrogé sur la diplomatie il
faut que s'agissant la France s'agissant
de notre impulsion auprès des autres
européens nous façons le maximum pour
que cet accord au niveau européen puisse
être conclu si possible au premier
semestre nous devons donc pas laisser
des désaccords internes l'affaiblir
l'Europe doit
poursuivre le découplage entre
croissance économique et trajectoire de
ses émissions de gaz à effet de serre la
France souhaite donc l'adoption la plus
rapide possible d'un cadre énergieclimat
robuste pour 2030 sur la base je l'ai
indiqué il y a un instant de la
proposition de la Commission européenne
d'une réduction de 40 % de nos émissions
2030 par rapport à
1990 en tant que future présidence nous
devrons être des facilitateurs des
discussions globales sur le climat en
2014 c'estd cette année nous ne sommes
pas et nous devons pas être au tout
premier rang parce que l'actuelle
présidence polonaise et la future
présidence pévienne joue ce rôle il y
aura vous savez à Lima au mois de
décembre l'équivalent mais non conclusif
de ce que sera Paris climat 2015 mais
même si nous vons accompagner ce
mouvement sans le diriger nous forgeons
dès aujourd'hui notre méthode
c'est-à-dire une présidence qui veut
être offensive mais qui a besoin
d'écouter qui doit savoir convaincre
mais qui commencera par comprendre et
qui ne veut pas de consensus artificiel
le multiratarisme est évidemment
fondamental et c'est ce qui nous
inspirera pour construire la confiance
pour pouvoir le moment venu faire
adopter un accord et donc il faut le
pratiquer en dehors du cadre strict des
négociations
nous devrons aussi à la construction
d'un élan politique fort au plus haut
niveau d'ors et déjà c'est la raison de
ma présidence j'ai mobilisé toutes nos
ressources diplomatiques et à chaque
rencontre bilatérale ou multilatérale
qui se produit et à laquelle je
participe ou les secrétaires d'État à
chaque réunion du G7 ou du G20 nous
plaçons le climat à l'ordre du jour
notre objectif c'est que l'enjeu
climatique prenne la place de premier
plan qui doit être la sienne dans les
priorités de nos interlocuteurs une
autre orientation de notre
action
et de faire que ce soit une action
positive François mitteran utilisait
souvent une formule qui me faisait
sourire il disait si vous dites
aujourd'hui c'est difficile demain c'est
pire et je ne vous parle pas
d'après-demain mieux vaut choisir une
autre fonction et je pense qu'il avait
raison il s'appliquait à la politique en
général étant un expert de cette matière
mais si nous revenons à notre sujet je
crois que sans dorer la pilule il faut
que nous expliquions que c'est à notre
portée sinon nos concitoyens vont se
désintérêt de l'objectif et
désintéresser et nous ne pourrons
avancer nous devons donc à la fois sur
le plan diplomatique susciter un certain
nombre de coalitions novatrices faire la
la preuve par l'action mais aussi
rassembler mobiliser les
collectivités les entreprises les
acteurs étatique et non étatique sur
l'accès à l'énergie durable le transfert
de technologie la ville durable
l'agriculture le financement il y a déjà
des progrès par exemple j'étais à Davos
au début de l'année et deux très grandes
entreprises j'ai oublié la seconde mais
la première était un lever qui est
vraiment un des grands grandes
entreprises mondiales et des grands
polluant mondial ont pris des
engagements notamment de ne pas utiliser
la forêt indument donc il y a un
mouvement euh qui est lancé davantage de
ces de ces entreprises étaient
regroupées à Abu Dhabi au cours de ces
derniers jours elle vise à promouvoir
l'énergie propre en Afrique à conclure
un Pact des mers pour l'action
climatique et vous avez vu par exemple
que bad kimoun j'en dirai un mot dans un
instant qui est très mobilisé sur ce
sujet a désigné euh l'ancien maire de
New York monsieur Bloomberg pour être
son représentant pour vraiment impliquer
les collectivités locales et c'est une
excellente
idée qu'il s'agisse d'ailleurs de
l'action climatique de réduire les
fuites de méthane et cetera et ces
coalitions nous devons en faire une
cartographie ce sont ces messieurs qui
en sont chargés je vais vous expliquer
dans un instant ce qu'ils font et pour
que les choses comme aurait dit tard de
Chardin converge et que nous puissions à
condition que nous y pren rapidement le
temps est absolument central dans cette
affaire avoir à la fois la pesée des
états la pesé des organisations
internationales la pesée des
collectivités locales la pesée des
entreprises la pesée des ONG la pesée
des opinions publ tout cela convergeant
vers l'objectif souhaitable et l'un des
temps forts il y a beaucoup de temps
forts cette année en permanence il y a
des conférences sur ce sujet c'est très
bien mais l'un des temps forts va être
le sommet de l'ONU sur le climat que
notre ami le secrétaire général des
Nations unies Bank kimounon va
accueillir à New York le 23 septembre
c'est une date très importante car nous
essayons de faire en sorte avec
bankimoun que le maximum de leaders
mondiaux s'engage au nom de leur pays
car nous considérons que en regardant ce
qui a été fait à Copenhague et ce qui a
été fait dans différentes conférences il
y a plusieurs erreurs à éviter nous
n'avons pas apportter jugement critique
sur tel ou tel euh conférence mais
essayé de tirer les leçons et lorsque je
suis allé à Varsovie la dernière
conférence j'ai poser à tous les
interlocuteurs que j'ai rencontré la
même question
je j'avais pensé leur poser la question
mais comment fait-on pour réussir mais
je me suis dit ils vont être très
modestes et bon donc je leur ai posé une
question un peu détournée qui éit plus
intéressante Jeur dit quelles erreurs ne
faut-il pas commettre et ils ont été
très bavards à partir de cette question
question et en particulier j'en ai
conclu deux choses parmi d'autres
premièrement il est essentiel
que nous ayons des engagements le plus
vite possible car la mise en musique de
tout cela demande beaucoup de temps et
donc c'est la raison pour laquelle à
Varsovie il a été dit que les différents
pays devaient prendre des engagements au
maximum au début de l'année prochaine
certains pays de ce point de vue-là on
une situation difficile nos partenaires
américains nous ont expliqué que contenu
des midterm election n'était pas
possible et cetera mais il faut que le
maximum de pays s'engage et c'est là où
la journée de bankimon comme je
l'appelle de manière un petit peu
familière est très importante car si
vous avez de grands leaders mondiaux qui
viennent à la tribune des Nations Unies
dire en ce qui concerne mon pays voilà
ce qui se passe à ce moment-là il est
très difficile aux autres de se cacher
derrière le sent général et parmi les
pays don j'espère très très fortement
qu'ils pourront prendre un engagement il
y a évidemment la Chine président
chissiping était récemment à Paris pour
une visite qui a été à Lyon pour une
visite très réussie nous avons aborder
avec le président français ces sujets et
avec le président chinois et à partir du
moment où les Chinois c'est un
changement majeur par rapport auparavant
sont vraiment convaincus qu'ils doivent
bouger cela a une force
extraordinaire que le président chizping
ou le Premier ministre l viennent à la
tribune des Nations Unies pour dire
voilà nous avons réfléchi voilà notre
engagement
car il y a évidemment d'autres pays qui
n'ont pas fait ce choix politique encore
et donc la première conclusion que j'ai
tiré c'est il faut que les engagements
soient rapides la deuxième conclusion
que j'ai tiré c'est que bien sûr les
politiques doivent s'engager c'est une
affaire qui au niveau de chaque nation
est décidé par le président Premier
ministre le gouvernement mais on ne peut
pas espérer que ce soit au dernier
moment que ces responsables réunis en
l'occurrence à Paris euh résolvve la
situation c'est ce qui avait été tenté à
copenhag moi je n'y étais pas mais on
m'a raconté cela où au dernier moment la
dernière nuit peut-être quelques
personnalités remarquables se sont
réunis dans un coin ils étaient 4 5 6 je
ne sais pas ils ont élaboré un texte
dont ils pensait que il allait être
décisif ils l'ont ramené devant
l'assemblée générale qui leura dit votre
texte vous pouvez le garder dans votre
poche bon donc il faut que les grands
politiques s'investissent au nom de leur
pays tôt mais il faut que le temps soit
laissé ensuite aux obstures techniciens
que nous sommes pour permettre de faire
les synthèses utiles et c'est par le va
vient entre ces deux éléments qu'on peut
espérer dans cette matière
extraordinairement difficile trouver un
accord d'autant que je signale vous le
savez parfaitement que c'est un accord
par consensus il fut un temps je ne
citerai personne qui n'est pas très
lointain où à l'issue de la conférence
le président de la conférence avait
demandé au participants à la conférence
que ce ceux qui sont pour VE bien lever
la
main que ceux qui sont contre veulent
bien lever la main personne n'est contre
c'est donc adopté mais ça je ne pense
pas que on puisse ni surtout qu'on doiv
le faire et donc le consensus doit être
réel ce qui a combien 180 et quelques
pays n'est pas d'une facilité aveuglante
c'est la raison pour laquelle je dis
tout ça en plantant lorsque la France
qui d'ailleurs étaé la seule candidate a
obtenu cette conférence en général quand
on est seul candidat ça facilite quand
même la victoire ceux qui sont venus me
saluer m'ont dit dans un même souffle
félicitations et ils ajoutaient tout bas
condoléance donc j'ai j'oublie la
deuxème partie de la phrase je pense que
c'est une grande responsabilité une très
grande responsabilité pour la France
mais qu'il faut prendre les dispositions
pratiques pour essayer de mettre tous
nos atout tous les atouts de nos côtés
et de ce point de vue-là l'engagement
personnel et très fort du
secrétairegénéral bankimoun est quelque
chose de évidemment très important ces
initiatives des uns et des autres des
nations des organisations des
collectivités de l'ONU et cetera doivent
constituer la rampe de lancement du
futur accord et créer un contexte
favorable au progrès de la négociation
politique quelques mots sur
l'implication de la société civile et
sur l'organisation matérielle de tout
cela la société civile dans son ensemble
évidemment un rôle tout à fait majeur à
jouer pour peser positivement sur le
succès de la négociation en entre état
c'est notamment pourquoi sur le plan
logistique nous mettons en œuvre le
maximum pour créer les meilleures
conditions possible d'accueil et
d'accessibilité en direction de la
société civile et aussi bien sûr des
médias ces acteurs feront beaucoup ils
ont commencé d'ailleurs pour assurer la
visibilité de cet événement qui devra
aussi être exemplaire du point de vue de
l'impact environnemental et nous a-t-il
semblé de l'implication des citoyens
puisque çaa Liu au Bourget même si
s'appelle Paris c'est au Bourget et du
département de la scène saint le rôle de
la société civile en décembre 2015 ne va
pas se limiter aux de semaines de la COP
il y a énormément à faire d'ici là les
parlementaires et plus particulièrement
les sénateurs peuvent aider nos efforts
français de plusieurs façons tout à
l'heure je parlais de l'exemplarité
française sur le climat j'attire
notamment votre attention sur la
ratification de la deuxème période
d'engagement du protocole de Kyoto qui
va vous être transmise prochainement et
sur laquelle la France et l'Union
européenne sont attendus d'autre part il
existe un potentiel de mobilisation des
collectivité territoriale que vous
représentez particulièrement autour de
l'enjeu climatique comme l'a indiqué le
rapport des sénateurs dantech et Delbar
je salue l'un de ces jumeaux puisque
maintenant l'un pas citer sans l'autre
plus de la moitié des émissions
mondiales sont liées c'est ce que disent
nos deux amis sénateur à des décisions
prises localement l'échelle
internationale est la meilleure échelle
pour créer une impulsion politique et
des outils mais l'échelle locale disyle
est la meilleure pour les mettre en
œuvre donc là le Sénat les sénateurs ont
un rôle tout à fait important à jouer
enfin les parlementaires peuvent et
doivent remplir une fonction de
facilitateur dans les négociations
national là aussi j'emprunte le terme de
facilitateur au rapport de monsieurs
Dantec et gelb par des échanges au sein
de groupe d'amitiers par vos
participations au COP au sein de la
délégation française par les coalitions
internationales de parlementaires autour
du climat vous pouvez et j'espère vous
allez contribuer à la préparation des
décisions prises par les législateurs
nationaux pour beaucoup de pays la
préparation des contributions nationales
à l'accord 2015 va faire l'objet d'une
sanction législative il il faut garder
aussi à l'esprit qu'au lendemain de la
COP 21 c'est à ce niveau parlementaire
que tout se jouera pour que l'accord ne
reste pas lettre morte donc on prenne
les choses en amont en aval ou au milieu
vous avez vraiment un rôle très
important à jouer et connaissant la
sensibilité du du Sénat tout gros
profondu là-dessus je je sais que vous
le Jez voilà quelques éléments sur notre
démarche et nos attentes pour la COP 21
je veux dire en je terminerai par là
quelques aspects matériels alors comment
travaille on en interne si je puis dire
euh à partir des indications donné par
le Président de la République et le
Premier ministre
euh il y a
essentiellement deux trois secteurs
ministériels qui sont mobilisés bon
d'abord le Kedor puisquil a été choisi
pour avoir la présidence au nom de notre
réseau diplomatique bon c'est de ça
qu'il s'agit et évidemment en tant que
patron du kedorset je mobilise tous nos
ambassadeurs au cours de cette année de
l'année prochaine sur cet objectif et
par exemple vous savez sans doute que se
réunit la conférence des ambassadeurs à
la fin du mois d'août chaque année et
l'un des thèmes centraux sera comment on
prépare la COP 21 parce que nous avons
le 3è réseau diplomatique du monde et si
chaque ambassadeur fait son travail et à
chaque fois que les sujets sont posés
ajoute ce sujetl c'est un un comment
dire phénomène
positif qui qui se développe et dont
nous avons absolument besoin
le la ministre de
l'écologie mène la délégation française
parce qu'il faut qu'il ait une action
française donc j'ai dit qu'elle doit
être exemplaire et elle doit aussi en
liaison avec le qu d'Orsa jouer un rôle
au sein de la démarche européenne et
puis madame Gerardin qui est secrétaire
d'État chargé du développement qui a
pris la suite de monsieur campfin va
aussi Inter venir sur ce sujet ainsi que
quelques personnalités j'en cite deux
qui sont là d'une part l'ambassadeur
Lapouge qui est ici qui est grand
spécialiste de ces questions et qui va
coordonner notre travail là-dessus dans
la négociation proprement dite qui est
épouvantablement technique et d'ut part
monsieur Guignard qui est le secrétaire
général qui s'occupe en partiulier de
l'organisation matérielle de tout cela
parce que c'est absolument colossal je
vous ai dit enfin cité ch chire je crois
20000 délégués euh donc là plus tous
ceux qui voudront se rajouter c'est un
événement qui matériellement est très
très complexe à organiser donc nous
avons commencé à travailler
là-dessus il y a à peu près un an je
crois euh évidemment nous sommes nous
devons être remplir uniquement notre
rôle nous ne sommes pas encore les
présidents en titre puisque il faut
travailler avec nos nos voisins et amis
pérouviens polonais et cetera ça se
passe bien et au plan interne j'ai le
plaisir de réunir à peu près chaque mois
chaque mois et demi ce qu'on appelle
dans un jargon horrible COPIL je crois
que ça veut dire comité de pilotage vous
avez des copiles chacun chez vous et
autour de la COP 21 et
donc autour de de la table
ok sont réunis à la fois les ministres
et leurs directeurs compétents et puis
un certain nombre de spécialistes que je
veux pas compromettre en citant tous
leur nom mais notre Amic est là et un
certain nombre de grands spécialistes du
climat et puis il y a aussi monsieur
HULLOT qui est le représentant du
président de la République et puis
madame Marien Aubert enfin tous ceux qui
un titre ou un autre ont un rôle
administrativo politique sont là pour
que dis on les les choses soient bien
accordées et pour le moment les disputes
n'ont pas franchi les murs du kéorset ça
se passe extrêmement bien d'ailleurs si
ça se passait pas bien okors al vraiment
ce serait à désespéré non le travail
avance bien il faut que nous fassions
vraiment un travail de préparation très
très très précis parce que c'est très
très compliqué ces affaires et en même
temps que nous nutrepassions pas notre
rôle parce qu'il faut pas croire que la
présidence c'est elle qui va donner le
là et dire c'est comme C c'est comme ça
car il y a toute une série
d'organisations ADP et cetera enfin les
sigle Floris au fur à mesure que les
jours passent qui qui sont là et il faut
plutôt être face facilitateur
synthétiseur plutôt que Grand Architecte
de l'Univers c'est pas comme ça que ça
se passe euh donc voilà l'organisation
matérielle alors évidemment il y a des
aspects financiers il y a des aspects
politiques il y a toute une série de
présences à organiser euh et nous avons
nous n'avons pas perdu de temps mais il
y a pas de temps à perdre là nous sommes
au mois de mai il y a toute une série de
conférences là qui ont lieu en ce moment
il va un grand événement qui vaer au
mois de juillet à Paris porté économique
ensuite on va se projeter dans le sommet
de batkimou de septembre ensuite
directement vers la COP de Lima au Pérou
préparé par une
COP préparatoire au Venezuela quelques
semaines auparavant et puis on saute
directement dans l'année 2015 à Lima
normalement il devrait y avoir un ours
bien ou mal léché je ne sais pas qui
soit un premier épuche de texte ensuite
nous demandons au pays de prendre des
positions nationales petit à petit euh
l'accord converge il faut que nous
occupions très précisément des mesures
de financement il y aura certainement
des questions là-dessus parce que
beaucoup de pays nous disent ils ont
tout à fait raison ou c'est très bien
votre affaire mais comment financer moi
je suis un pays en développement je n'ai
pas les moyens donc c'est l'affaire du
fond vert c'est tout ça et il faut
mettre dans le coup euh tous ceux qui
peuvent financer
euh et puis il y a une cartographie
politique à bâtir pour que ceux qui sont
les plus réticents veuillent bien au fur
à mesure abandonner leur réticence alors
certaines réticences sont
compréhensibles on pense aux petites
îles à d'autres qui n'ont pas les mêmes
enjeux parce quex c'est la vie ou la
mort d'autres ce sont des réticences
liées à leur niveau de développement à
leur manque de moyens financiers
d'autres ce sont des résistances
politiques car il y a quelques pays qui
disent non non non bah
voilà bon le problème existe enfin après
tout chacun chez soi et donc c'est il
faut mettre en en synergie tout cela et
faire en sorte rien n'est acquis que en
ce mois de
décembre 2015 nous puissions
enregistrer un succès voilà quelques
éléments mais je suis à vos disposition
pour des réponses plus précises euh je
réfléchissais à cela le le mot COP 21
bon c'est un peu mystérieux hein on se
demande quelle est la société secrète
COP 21 bon et en fait 21 c'est parce
qu'il y a eu 20 conférences avant si
j'ai bien compris mais c'est aussi
significatif que ce soit le 21 du 21e
siècle et donc il faut que petit à petit
euh dans l'opinion
et on doit s'appuyer sur les opinions
publiques notamment les opinions jeunes
des des des jeunes euh nous nous nous
accréditions l'idée légitime que c'est
une responsabilité internationale
absolument massive que il s'agit pas
d'une conférence comme une autre où on
discute de modalités il s'agit à
proprement parler de la condition de la
possibilité d'existence de la vie
humaine et je pense que si nous arrivons
à cela sans survaloriser nos mérites euh
c'est un thème que je développe souvent
quand je parle politique avec AC les
dirigeants que je rencontre ça donne de
la politique peut-être une idée un peu
différente et peut-être un peu meilleure
que celle qui nous est souvent reprochée
on nous dit oui mais la politique c'est
quelque chose d'obscur d'un petit peu
crapot oui mais là il s'agit vraiment de
préparer le futur et il s'agit pas
d'intérêt égoïste ni égoïste d'un point
de vue national ni égoïste d'un point de
vue temporel il s'agit que le politique
avec un grand paix retrouve ses droits
qui est faire en sorte que la vie en
société sur la terre
soit possible et soit meilleur et je
pense que c'est un élément qui peut si
nous réussissons faire regagner du
crédit au politique en général voilà
monsieur le Président Mesdames et
Messieurs sénateurs ce que je voulais
vous dire en quelques mots c'est un défi
très difficile mais avec l'aide du Sénat
rien n'est
impossible monsieur le ministre merci
merci pour C excellente exposé alors les
questions donc les premières questions
Monsieur Marcel den ronand Michel
testonv
R et Louis Nigre voilà on va commencer
donc par Monsieur Marcel den oui ça
tombe bien monsieur le ministre merci de
votre exposé vous avez campé descs moi
j'avoue que je partage votre constat et
rien ne me choque dans ce que vous avez
dit ni par les cheminement av venir
alors je voudrais vous faire part d'une
partie de mon expérience qui n'est pas
grande mais j'apporte ma pierre à
l'édifice en
2001 2002 j'ai fait le premier rapport
sur les évolution climatique dans le
cadre de l'Office Parlementaire des
évaluations technologiques et j'ai à ce
titre là eu la chance d'être dans la
délégation parlementaire qui était allée
à Johannesbourg et je vous dis ça pour
que nos amis comprennent l'ambiance de
l'époque j'ai participé j'ai assisté
dans la même
salle à ce discours dont on parle la
maison brûle et vous regardons ailleurs
le matin et l'après-midi dans la même
salle le même auditoire à siffler le
représentant des US c'était l'époque où
le président des USA on vivait encore
sur cette grande déclaration le mode de
vie des Américains n'est pas négociable
c'était cette époque 15 ans hein bon
alors je vous dis ça et j'ai mesuré ce
soir-là la difficulté de mettre d'accord
l'ensemble de la communauté
internationale je me suis dit on a quand
même beaucoup de choses qui nous
séparent comment va-t-on faire alors
vous ayant dit cela moi dans ce que vous
avez dit il y a des choses que je veux
appuyer et
rappeler nous avons beaucoup de chance
d'être la France pour l'organisation de
cette réunion internationale parce que
on ne le dit pas à ass la France est
plutôt vertueuse dans ce système et nous
avons une crédibilité réelle s'il
fallait le chiffrer quels sont les
éléments de chiffrage les meilleurs pour
apprécier en matière de de production de
CO2 par habitant la France c'est 5
tonnes 8 moi je travaille beaucoup en ce
moment les affaires d'énergie avec
l'Allemagne l'Allemagne c'est 9 tonnes
et la moyenne européenne elle est
quelque part dans ces niveaul donc la
France a une base de de départ très
crédible pour être ceux qui organisent
et qui peuvent dans une certaine mesure
montrer le chemin vertueux et le dire
c'est à notre portée ce que vous avez
firmé il faut le dire c'est à notre
portée alors ayant dit cela comment on
chemine moi je partage tous les points
de vue je ne serai plus parlementaire
l'année prochaine mais je continuerai à
participer à mon niveau mais la question
que je voudrais vous poser c'est comment
allons-nous nous servir du
multilatéralisme avec l'expérience des
négociations diplomatiques que vous avez
et qui a manqué à Copenhague moi j'étais
à Copenhague en fait nous n'avons pas eu
l'expérience de la négociation
diplomatique pour 36 raisons
d'organisation locale et même de
participation française il était
difficile d'aboutir au bout de de jours
on en était conscient alors comment
mettrez-vous au service du système votre
habitude de la négociation diplomatique
et puis une question plus précise
comment comptez-vous vous servir des 700
millions d'habitants qui composent
l'Union pour la Méditerranée qui se sont
réunis fin janvier qui doivent encore se
réunir à Athènes ce mois-ci autant que
je sache et qui sont porteurs d'un
avenir dans la mesure où leur existance
à eux est tout à fait mise en cause
parce qu'il se prépare en matière de
réchauffement qui tique étant donné que
la France est quelque part dans la
situation d'un pays charnière dans cette
affaire autrement dit il y a là avec
Union pour la Méditerranée et votre
compétence des négociations
diplomatiques un levier dont il faut se
servir alors Monsieur ronand dc si on
peut monsieur le ministre n'aura pas le
temps de répondre à toutes les questions
si chacun ne fait pas un petit effort
donc Monsieur ronand D oui donc pour
pour être rapide mais je crois que
présentation de Laurent fbus était
extrêmement clair sur les sur les
objectifs de la France et sur sur
l'analyse peut-être juste en complément
puisque il se trouve que j'ai atterri
d'Abu Dhabi à 15h donc je je reviens
avec justement un petit peu le le
feeling de de ce qui s'est passé à Abu
Dhabi je crois qu'il est important de
comprendre que collectivement peut-être
pas de manière consensuelle mais assez
majoritairement l'ensemble des acteurs
ne veulent pas revivre copenhag ça je
crois que c'est extrêmement clair et que
il y a un sentiment partagé qui
finalement le succès de Paris
c'est que au lendemain de Paris les
acteurs sont en mouvement puisque
aujourd'hui je crois comme Laurent
Fabius l'a très bien dit le le
climatoscepticisme est en train de de
battre en retraite et scientifiquement
démontrer l'origine humaine mais il y a
un espèce de climatoofatalisme qu'il a
remplacé sur le fait que finalement
l'effort est tel que il n'est pas
accessible et que du coup on peut
peut-être se replier les uns les autres
sur sur son territoire ce qui serait la
pire des choses et donc il faut
absolument que l' en main de la COP et
c'est la responsabilité de la France
l'ensemble des acteurs du citoyen à la
multinationale sot en mouvement avec
l'idée que c'est accessible dans le
courant du du du 21e siècle donc je
crois que c'est ce que Banky Moon euh
porte euh avec le sommet de de septembre
pour information donc moi j'ai présenté
avec les les représentants des autres
réseaux mondiaux le le compact of mayor
qui complète assez bien la nomination de
blondberg et on essaiera de présenter à
New York finalement un tonnage agrégé de
l'ensemble des actions des des des
villes mais pas que que des grandes je
crois que c'est important de de montrer
que ce sont tous les territoires qui
sont en mouvement et ma ma remarque
peut-être pour être justement rapide
c'est que j'ai aussi assisté à l'atelier
finances et ce qui est quand même assez
marquant c'est dans le propos de de
Christina figuerz que la la question du
fond vert reste quand même assez
centrale aujourd'hui sur le fait que si
les pays développés ne tiennent pas
l'engagement de Copenhague l'un des
rares engagements de Copenhague alors
euh il sera difficile de de créer la
confiance en quel il peut pas y avoir
d'accord ce qui veut dire je me retourne
un peu finalement vers les uns et les
autres puisque Laurent Fabius a un peu
interpellé les parlementaires qui est
que demain si nous voulons l'accord il
nous faudra aussi faire un effort
financier direct ou indirect et qu'il
faudrait pas que demain tous ceux qui se
disent le climat c'est extrêmement
important finalement rechigne au moment
où il faudra quand même sortir d'une
manière ou d'une autre le carnet de
chèque je crois que ça c'est un enjeu
majeur il faut être conscient que si
nous ne tenons pas la promesse de
Copenhague nous ne créerons pas la la
dynamique à Paris en 2 en
2015 merci Monsieur michel Teston merci
monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre et ancien Premier ministre je
souhaite vous poser brièvement deux
questions elle pte sur le positionnement
de l'Union européenne de la Chine au
cours de la
conférence il me paraît absolument
nécessaire que l'Union européenne parle
d'une seule et même voix au cours de la
conférence donc ma question est simple
comment l'Union européenne se
prépare-t-elle et de quelle manière on
peut penser en effet que certains États
européens qui sont effectivement euh
intéressés par l'exploitation de leur
ressources fossiles n'auront peut-être
pas la même position que d'autres et la
deuxème question euh on a entendu que le
président chinois vous vous l'avez
d'ailleurs cité dans votre intervention
a annoncé des réformes économiques et
qui consisteraient à répartir les
bénéfices finalement du développement
plus équitablement tout en diminuant la
pollution est-ce que ça peut se traduire
lors de la conférence par un changement
du discours diplomatique chinois ce qui
serait absolument nécessaire
oui très rapidement monsieur le ministre
j'ai été particulièrement sensible aux
arguments que vous avez développé pour
témoigner de l'importance de cette
conférence en appelant d'ailleurs à un
élan politique fort euh à des
engagements les plus rapides possible je
considère que la France a un rôle
central et vous l'avez bien compris à
jouer dans cette dimension si
particulière pour le devenir de
l'humanité toutefois en revenant à des
considérations beaucoup plus bassement
matérialiste et filant la la question de
mon collègue Teston sur la capacité de
l'Union européenne à agir plus
collectivement j'ai la prétention de
considérer qu'aujourd'hui sur le
territoire national des collectivités
territoriales ont manifesté des des
intentions très forte dans la
réalisation d'équipements structurants
qui permettrai d'abaisser
significativement l'empreinte carbone et
je pense plus particulièrement un grand
projet qui peut concerner jusqu'à
l'ouest de notre pays je pense au canal
cnord Europe ne serait-il pas judicieux
en amont de cette conférence que la
nation française accompagnée par les
décisions que l'Europe a déjà arrêté
dans le cadre du financement de cette
infrastructure les collectivités
territoriales ayant déjà témoigné de
leur intérêt et de leur cofinancement
sur cette structure une décision
positive pu être annoncé pour montrer en
la matière l'exemplarité de la nation
française qui serait une bonne manière
d'accueillir les autres continents pour
la réussite de ce Paris climat 2015
merci Monsieur Madame Hélène
conymoné merci monsieur le Président
Monsieur le le ministre tout d'abord
vous féliciter de vous être saisi d'un
d'un sujet aussi vaste c'est un acte
courageux non pas parce qu'il y avait
beaucoup de de concurrents puisque la
France était le seul pays pays mais au
vu des enjeux à à relever et puis aussi
au vu des des réticences peut-être que
nous voyons de la mise en œuvre des
objectifs qui avaient été dessinés lors
des conférences précédentes et réticence
donc de mise en œuvre de de ceci ma
question va porter simplement sur le
financement de de la conférence je crois
qu'aujourd'hui il est très important de
sensibiliser le le plus grand nombre
nous avons un besoin de travailler dans
la la transparence et au vu de du climat
économique que nous connaissons même si
les enjeux sont importants de pouvoir
sensibiliser le le plus grand nombre et
donc de savoir comment cette conférence
sera
financée merci Monsieur Yve Pozo di
Borgo
oui monsieur le ministre vous AZ
commencé votre intervention en faisant
allusion au aux grandes masses
glaciaires qui fonde et récemment avec
le groupe d'amitié arctique Antarctique
terre australe du Sénat et la Fondation
Luc nué que je préside nous avons
organisé un colloque sur l'article et où
notamment nous avons une une
intervention très forte de Michel Rocard
qui s'inquiétait du fait que les huit
pays les h pays rivérins en fait
bloquaient les choses et que l'article
comm l'Antarctique d'ailleurs était qui
était en fait surtout l'Artic puisqu
qu'on avit pr de l'Artique qui était
quand même un des éléments de cet
changement climatique était en fait aux
mains de H pays et que c'était pas
ouvert alors la question que je vous
pose c'est de savoir dans quelle mesure
alors je sais qu'il y a un rapport de
notre collègue gâolin là-dessus qui vait
sortir au Sénat je veux savoir quel son
les mesures éventuellement qui pour être
envisagé durant cette conférence merci
Madame leilla
ai merci Monsieur le Ministre merci
monsieur le Président je voulais
apporter
quelques précisions s'il vous plaît par
rapport à votre à votre exposé j'ai le
14 février dernier organisé au sein de
du Sénat un débat sur l'Europe de la
défense autour de du Livre vert de la
défense des écologistes qui porte le
concept de Green defense dans lequel
nous nous abordons évidemment les les
sujets de problématique environnemental
de prévention des conflits d'accès aux
matières premières et évidemment du
dérèglement climatique donc avec un
prisme évidemment environnemental et
également avec une approche de défense
sur ce sujet cont tenu du fait que
précisément en ce qui concerne notre
notre défense et la première emprise
foncière et qu'une transition
environnementale et et énergétique ne
peut pas se faire sans l'armée et que à
titre d'exemple l'armée améri améric
consomme à peu près 360000 barils de
pétrole par jour à savoir plus de la
consommation journalière de la
Suède le secrétaire général des nations-
Unies monsieur ben kimoun reconnaît
lui-même que le dérèglement climatique
est une donnée enfin est un risque
majeur stratégique et nous même dans le
Livre vert de la défense des écologistes
nous considérons que le dérèglement
climatique doit être intégré comme une
donnée stratégique pour notre défense et
de construire tout le sujet de la
défense et la construction de notre de
notre outil militaire autour de ce de ce
sujet éminemment important pour les
décennies à venir je voudrais avoir
votre sentiment monsieur le ministre sur
la manière dont vous abordez ce sujet du
dérèglement climatique en lien
évidemment avec les conflits
environnementaux et une des
recommandations que nous avons fait dans
le cadre de notre livre justement c'est
dans le cadre du COP 21 d'intégrer et
d'organiser une réunion des ministres de
la Défense cont tenu du fait
qu'indépendamment du fait qu'il soit ou
non écologistes leurs propres
contraintte d'organisation interne de
par le fait qu'ils consomment beaucoup
d'énergie ils sont soumis à à ces
contraintes donc je voulez également
avoir votre sentiment puisque ça fait
partie de la première recommandation du
Livre vert donc d'organiser en 2015 à
Paris une réunion des ministres de la
Défense autour du dérèglement climatique
comme une donnée stratégique pour nos
armées je vous remercie merci Monsieur
Louis
monsieur le ministre merci de
votre exposé liminire qui était
particulièrement intéressant et qui
mettait bien l'accent sur ce qu'il
fallait euh examiner aujourd'hui alors
pensée globale agir localement vous avez
dit la France doit être exemplaire je
vous rejoins assez facilement sur ce
point-là et plutôt qu'une question
j'aurais deux propositions à vous faire
la première c'est de d'avoir une
politique plus pédagogique à l'égard du
grand public parce que nous n'arriverons
pas à avancer si le grand public lui
n'est pas convaincu de la nécessité
d'agir et je reprends donc la la FP de
15h qui annonce le fameux discours
d'Obama et Obama va utiliser la route
numéro 1 en Louisiane pour démontrer que
cette route est en train de s'enfoncer
et que ça va coûter 7,8 milliards
d'euros notamment au pétrolier pour
récupérer ça c'est quelque chose de
simple c'est quelque chose de concret
c'est quelqueose chose que tout le monde
peut comprendre et donc je souhaiterais
qu'on soit plus pédagogue j'aborde le
problème non pas au niveau de la
conférence vous le voyez mais de manière
terre à terre par le petit bout de la
lorniette deè
proposition il faudrait intervenir
beaucoup plus fortement sur les
transports vous savez que les gaz à
effet de serre proviennent en grande
partie au moins 30 % des gaz donc des
transports et je suggère fortement
puisque la France a une position plutôt
en pointe dans le domaine du véhicule
électrique grâce notamment à deux choses
un mix qui est énergétique qui nous est
favorable et deuxièmement parce que
Renault constructeur mondial s'est lancé
là-dedans et bien je suggère fortement
au gouvernement je l'ai dit au ministre
du redressement productif je l'ai dit au
ministre donc de l'environnement et je
vous le dis je je suggère fortement que
le gouvernement a une action dans ce
domaine beaucoup plus forte qu'il ne l'a
actuellement pour faire en sorte que les
collectivités locales les flottes
d'entreprises les flottes euh des de nos
communautés d'agglomération et davantage
voir les ministères et davantage de
véhicules électriques qui pourraient
servir d'exemple aux
autres madame Éveline Didier madame
Éveline Didier excusez-moi monsieur le
Président euh merci Monsieur le Ministre
de la précision d'otre de votre exposé
et de son exhaustivité
euh plusieurs questions ont trouvé
réponse à travers ce que vous avez dit
donc je ne m'en tiens là simplement
comment la question sociale est prise en
compte dans ce travail qui est fait pour
la
préparation de Paris 2015 ça c'est ma
première question la deuxième de grands
pays jusqu'ici ont été très réticents je
pense notamment à l'Australie au Canada
est-ce que vous pensez qu'il est
raisonnable d'envisager que ils vont
rejoindre le concert des grandes nations
pour essayer de lutter contre le
réchauffement climatique euh le fond
vert effectivement comme l'a dit
Monsieur Dantec c'est c'est quelque
chose d'assez symbolique pouvez-vous
nous indiquer quelle est la
participation demandée à la
France et enfin euh on parle de
pédagogie euh mon collègue citait
quelques exemples moi je je dirais que
rien ne va pouvoir être gagné sans les
médias or les souvenirs que j'ai des
différentes conférences Pr précédente
les le le jeu médiatique a consisté à à
chercher toutes les fautes que faisaient
les parlementaires ou ou les les membres
du
gouvernement à l'extérieur on en a fait
une aventure politicienne alors même que
là comme dirait mon collègue Daniel
Renner le la maison brûle et et comment
faire en sorte que les médias soient à
la fois engagés et responsables dans
cette et et qu'il ne ne transforme pas
ça en en petite bisebille
médiatique Madame Chantal
jouanon bonjour monsieur le ministre
merci pour votre exposé j'ai eu la
malchance d'être à Copenhague et la
chance de pasasiette comme politique et
donc d'avoir accès à peu près à à tout
et notamment aux négociations préalable
dans ce qui s'est passé à copenhag c'est
que la négociation préalable des experts
et diplomatiques a échoué et qu'on est
arrivé le jour où les chefs d'État
entraent dans la négociation avec un
texte où il resta 90 points en
négociation l'échec était en partie dû à
des problèmes d'organisation et a
l'impossibilité de mettre autour de la
table les représentants du
G77 donc la question qui se pose
aujourd'hui c'est serons-nous CAPAES
d'éviter cette nouvelle erreur de de
procédure il semble que l'évolution de
la Chine comme vous l'avez signalé soit
plutôt fav able et que le la volonté
finalement de laisser les acteurs
prendre des engagements volontaires et
d'être moins exigeant que ce qu' avait à
Copenhague soit aussi plus
favorable mais qu'en est-il de notre
relation nous européens avec l'Afrique
parce qu'on a vu sur la conférence de
Nagoya sur un autre sujet qui était
difficile que la relation UE Afrique a
permis de faire aboutir cette conférence
est-ce qu'on une on a une action
particulière vis-à-vis de de l'Afrique
et d'autre part quel est votre sentiment
sur l'évolution du discours du Brésil
qui là aussi est par contre est
peut-être moins positif que ce qu'elle
nétait auparavant enfin bon je reprendi
pas les les ce qui a été dit sur le fond
vert et que je partage par Monsieur DC
et Madame Didier le dernier point sur
les collectivités qu'est-ce que vous
prévoyez pour les régions parce que
c'est vrai qu'on a vu que sur la plupart
des négociation elles ont un rôle très
proactif et beaucoup plus ambitieux que
la plupart des des gouvernements
le ministre merci
beaucoup je regarde bon al on va aller
au Galot hein ah
madame allez-y madame donc la dernière
allez-y madame monsieur le ministre
évidemment comme tous mes collègues je
vous remercie c'était un exposé clair
extrêmement pédagogique j'admire surtout
votre enthousiasme parce que vous avez
même dit que vous enleviez le mot
condoléance au mot félicitation bravo
mais peut-être que malgré tout je ne
partage pas nous avons auditionné il y a
au mois de juin dernier dans cette même
commission madame Connie Edgard qui est
donc commissaire européen au au climat
et qui a manifesté son inquiétude et qui
nous a même dit que la l'incertitude
quant au résultat de cette conférence
était un cauchemar quotidien j'emploie
les mots qu'elle avait employé à
l'époque et elle avait surtout
évidemment invoqué les problèmes
économiques qui qui contrebalance
évidemment le la volonté de de respecter
tout ce qui est écologique et clatique
alors je voulais vous poser une question
il y a un certain nombre de personnes
qui se posent des problèmes concernant
le nouveau traité
transatlantique il paraîtrait et je
parle sous votrement il paraîtrait que
le gouvernement serait prêt dans les
négociations actuelles
à donner la possibilité aux firmes
multinationales je je je prends les
termes qui ont été employés he
d'attaquer les états devant les
tribunaux si les réglementations
publiques faisaient obstacle à
l'investissement et au profit évidemment
si cela est exact et je voudrais avoir
votre sentiment là-dessus serait un
véritable dumping
écologique grave et donc ça serait
évidemment au niveau de l'image de la
France comme leader comme vertueuse et
comme exemplaire quelque chose
d'inquiétant juste un mot pour reprendre
ce qu' dit mon collègue on entend tout
le temps au niveau pédagogique dire la
hauteur de l'eau de 50 à 1 m ce n'est
absolument pas parlant ce qui est
parlant c'est de savoir jusqu'où elle va
dans les terres jeétait juste parce que
j'entends tout le temps dernière
question madame Joel garot Mélan oui
merci monsieur le Président très
rapidement vous nous avez demandé en
tant que sénateur d'être acteur de la
promotion de cette conférence nous le
serons bien évidemment mais je voudrais
souligner l'importance d'acteurs souvent
oubliés qui sont les Français de
l'étranger qui peut vous être très utile
dans ce domaine et je pense en
particulier au réseau de nos lycées
français à l'étranger où nous
scolarisons très souvant les enfants des
élites locales et qui peuvent être un
moyen
insoupçonné de nous aider et en plus ces
enfants et leurs enseignants sont très
concernés sur cette question bon je
pense une initiative que je soutiens du
lycée de Milan avec en partenariat avec
le lycée du du Sénégal de Dakar parce
que vous savez que nous avons un énorme
problème de monter des eaux à
Saint-Louis du Sénégal et je crois que
là nous pouvons vraiment fédérer
beaucoup de bonne volontés dans le monde
entier
bien merci euh je remercie ceux qui ont
posé questions je remercie aussi ceux
qui ne l'ont pas poser
euh parce que le temps est est limité
donc j'espère que vous m'excuserez si
euh je suis euh lacunaire euh cela n'est
pas dû seulement à mon incompétence mais
vraiment au manque de temps parce que je
veux pas être en retard pour pour la
suite de mon programme alors d'autant
que dans beaucoup de cas il s'agissait
de question et d'observation et qui qui
n'y a pas à à commenter euh monsieur
denu a souligné la crédibilité de la
France et il a dit mais quelle technique
diplomatique bon je ne suis pas
diplomate de profession mais
euh j'essaie de m'y mettre euh mais vous
savez
euh vous nous avons établi une espèce de
Cartographie
politique il y a des pays qui sont pour
employer un terme vulgaire très allant
d'autres qui sont plus réticents
d'autres qui sont très très réticents et
à partir de là nous essayons de bâtir
euh parce qu'on peut pas forcer un pays
qui ne veut pas quels sont les
coalitions que nous pouvons créer les
terme d'échange que nous pouvons
formuler euh nous le faisons j'en prends
un exemple au niveau européen dans un
instant nous essayion de le faire au
niveau mondial après c'est le jeu de la
discussion
et l'une d'entre vous disait mais vous
m'avez paru optimiste et Madame de garde
était plus pessimiste je ne suis pas
optimiste je suis volontariste et en
même temps je mesure l'immense
difficulté de cela si depuis des années
et des années les
cops amèneent certaines évolutions
parfois mê certains progrès mais non pas
réussi euh bon Zoro n'est pas dans cette
salle en tout cas je ne le connais pas
mais il faut avoir cet optimisme de la
volonté et de la nécessité ensuite mais
je suis incapable de vous dire avec 100
% de Chan que nous allons réussir en
tout cas nous devons être le maximum
d'atout de notre côté euh plusieurs
d'entre vous ont posé la question l'UPM
l'Afrique alors euh en l'UPM évidemment
nous allons essayer de de nous servir
entre guillemets de de de cette base
commune en ce qui concerne l'Afrique les
choses avancent assez bien je ne sais
pas c'est Madame Joanot notamment qui a
fait cette observation qui a posé cette
question je sais pas si vous avez
l'occasion de de jeter un œil sur les
conclusions de la réunion qui a eu lieu
à l'Élysée en décembre début décembre de
de l'année dernière où nous
avons passer une espèce d'accord avec
l'ensemble de nos amis africains puisque
51 pays étaient là pour dire que nous
allons aborder ensemble ces questions
évidemment le travail n'est pas fini
mais nous avons trouvé c'est notamment
monsieur lapouche qui s'occupe de ça
beaucoup de de volonté de bonne volonté
il est évident qu'à partir du moment où
nous serons d'accord d'avoir une base
commune avec nos amis africains ça nous
met en beaucoup meilleure position pour
parler notamment avec le comp 77 et avec
d'autres et c'est un objectif qui nous
semble apporter demain simplement et
j'en viens immédiatement à cette
question qui revient dans plusieurs de
vos observations euh ils posent tous la
question du financement et ils ont
raison euh et là-dessus euh nous savons
que ce sera un enjeu majeur pour
l'adoption de l'accord euh quel est
l'état des discussions et quel est
l'engagement de la France
bon le financement va être clé pour la
conclusion de l'accord d'abord parce que
c'est un enjeu de confiance entre les
développés et les pays en développement
ensuite parce que objectivement la
transition mondiale vers un un modèle
plus durable requier des investis
conséquent en 2014 il y a deux enjeux
principaux premièrement la
capitalisation du fond vert il faut que
nous assu une capitalisation initiale
ambitieuse du fond vert d'ici la fin de
cette année
et le fond maintenant il faut le rendre
opérationnel parceque la création a été
décidé il y a maintenant 4 ans et nous
allons procéder à contribuer à cette
première capitalisation et nous y
affecterons une part significative des
revenus de la
TTF deuxièmement nous avons on pris un
engagement collectif de dégager 100
milliards de dollars par an alors ça
peut paraître une somme énorme mais
quand on fait ces 100 milliards tout
tout compris y compris ce qu'apporte les
les ressources privées donc c'est à la
fois les ressources publiques et privées
d'ici à 2020 la capitalation du fond
vert va être un premier signal fort à
cet égard mais au-delà il faut que les
négociations progressent sur aspect
technique notamment sur la création d'un
cadre transparent et harmonisé en
portage des flux financiers et euh
l'accord de 2015 va être clé pour
parvenir à ces euh 100 milliards la
somme peut paraître énorme euh des
travaux ont commencé qui montrent que
c'est à notre portée euh et je
demanderais en particulier à une
personne que vous connaissez peut-être
qui est Madame Tubiana qui travaille
déjà à nos côtés qui est quelqu'un de
compétent et qui connaît bien ses sujets
de se pencher sur le côté financier et
l'agenda positif parce que euh c'est un
élément clé puisque je parle de
financement si j'ai compris madame
conouet qui qui malheureusement a dû
nous quitter elle posait aussi le
question de financement de la conférence
elle-même qui est une question
différente bon là nous sommes en train
de de travailler là-dessus c'est
Monsieur Guignard en particulier ici
présent qui s'en occupe ça dépend bien
sûr du cahier des charges des nations-
Unies qui est en cours de négociation
parce que c'est un élément important ça
dépend du nombre des participants ça
dépend de concept exact de la conférence
et d'autre part il faut que nous
reflétions dans notre organisation
l'esprit de la conférence c'estàdire
dire
écooresponsabilité capacité d'innover
une certaine modestie et ensuite nous
programmons le le financement et nous
l'inscrirons en PLF 2015 et 2016 bon il
faut voir aussi bon ça va coûter de
l'argent parce que quand on regarde les
précédents ça coûte de l'argent mais ça
c'est un investissement au sens le plus
noble que que fait la France il y aura
aussi sûrement des retombé pour la
France parce que quand vous avez 20000
personnes officiellement qui viennent et
encore quelques dizaines de milliers
d'autres évidemment c'est pour la
capitale et pour l'ensemble de la région
un apport mais euh ne soyons
pas hypocrite ou ou ou ou miope il y a
un coup non négligeable à cette
conférence dès que les choses auront été
un peu précisés évidemment je vous en
informerai d'ailleurs je devrais me
rendre au Bourget avec dès que les
choses auront un peu avancé pour
expliquer à la presse puisque plusieurs
d'entre vous on juste raison souigner
l'importance de la presse dans ce genre
de de rassemblement pour expliquer un
peu où nous en sommes alors Monsieur
Dantec a fait comme d'habitude des
observations pertinente j'aime bien sa
remarque climatcepticis non mais
attention au climatofatalistme il faut
faire attention à ça monsieur Teston
Union européenne Chine mais la question
a été posée par
d'autres Union européenne les
propositions de la Commission sont
intéressantes même si on peut discuter
tel ou tel détail nous sommes pas
arrivés encore à un accord
notamment parce que quelques pays ont
des difficultés je pense singulièrement
à la Pologne vous avez vu parce que la
Pologne est très dépendante de la Russie
elle a des ressources en gaz en charbon
qu'elle veut pas abandonner et cetera il
y a un part non négligeable qui a été
fait il y a de TR jours de ça c'est que
le premier ministre Tusk a dit que Contu
de la situation en Ukraine il fallait
aller vers une politique énergétique
européenne et nous avons emprunter le
même mouvement même si à l'intérieur de
ce qu'il pense être la politique
énergétique européenne il y a des
discussions à avir notamment sur
l'aspect charbon mais euh à quelque
chose malheur et bon si je peux dire
même si on souhaiterait éviter le
malheur je sens chez mes collègues par
rapport à ce qu'on a connu il y a 2 3
ans ou 5 ans ou 10 ans une prise de
conscience très très importante de la
nécessité d'avoir une politique
énergétique européenne avec trois
objectifs le premier c'est des coûts
plus bas le deuxième c'est la sécurité
d'approvisionnement et le troisième
c'est une politique qui soit compatible
avec les objectifs climatiques qui est
pas du tout le cas l'a jour il y avait
je crois que c'était dans le monde un
article tout à fait remarquable de
Monsieur mestralet que vous connaissez
il disait en mati européen c'est un
échec absolument lamentable pu seement
c'est très cher la sécurité n'est pas
assurée mais en plus le produit de tout
ce qui a été fait c'est qu'il y a plus
de charbon qu'avant donc si on voulait
échc il est là et
donc nous nous souhaitons nous allons
vraiment nous mobiliser pour faire
évoluer l'Union européenne dans le B
sens la Chine au moment même où c'était
il y a quelques semaines euh les
autorités décidaient de faire la
circulation alternée vous avez ça en
tête bon parce que je crois il y avait
eu 10 % ou 20 % de dépassement du seuil
à Paris je me trouvais à Pékin où la
pollution était un multiple
18 multiple 18 pas 10 % ou 20 % multiple
18 du seuil autorisé et par des
conversations aussi bien avec le
président chi que le premier ministre li
que beaucoup de d'amis ou de collègues
euh chinois c'est une vraie
préoccupation pour des raisons
sanitaires parce que bon il y a vraiment
des problèmes majeur pour des raisons
économiques parce
que il y a des cadres d'entreprises qui
ne veulent plus aller dans un certain
nombre de de de de villes chinoises
notamment à Pékin à cause de la
pollution et pour des raisons sociales
et politiques parce que la population
dit non et les dirigeants chinois sont
des gens très intelligents sensibles à
cela et donc euh
ils ont décidé de faire évoluer les
choses c'est très compliqué Contu du
développement mais j'ai plaidé au
président auprès du président ch je
retourne en Chine dans 10 jours et je le
referai auprès des autorités chinoises
pour que puisque la Chine a décidé c'est
nécessaire c'est indispensable et c'est
sincère de faire cette évolution et bien
comme je le disais dans mon propos
introductif évidemment ça changerait
énormément la donne mondiale si elle
faisait l'annonce de cette évolution et
notamment au moment de la conférence de
Monsieur Bank kimoun et c'est dans ce
sens que nous travaillons Monsieur R a
posé la question importante du Canal C
Nord Europe oui mais il y a d'autres
équipements aussi mais évidemment il ne
faut pas avoir une contradiction entre
les objectifs généraux qu'on affiche et
puis les équipements qu'on fait ou qu'on
ne fait pas Madame Conway avait posé la
question du financement j'aiessayé d'
répondre sur l'article oui vous avez
tout à fait raison monsieur Rocard et
monés représentant il est très très
compétent sur ces sujets il est très
passionnant là-dessus c'est vrai que sa
thèse que je crois juste c'est que un
certain nombre de pays contrôl ça alors
que quand on regarde non seulement en
terme climatique mais en terme
économique et
c'est région du monde qui concerne le
monde entier et donc la France a demandé
à pour être associé à tout cela un sujet
que nous avons présent à l'esprit
madamech je dois dire avec grande
honnêteté j'espère que vous m'en
pardonnerez avant les 20 prochaines
années que je n'ai pas lu le le Livre
vert sur la défense bah c'est gentil
d'ailleurs je vois qu'il est blanc mais
en revanche votre
idée est très intéressante et je vais en
parler mais ce n'est pas une fin de
recevoir à mon collègue leedant parce
que c'est pas une manière détournere de
dire attention la défense et faute de
mais ça concerne tous les collègues qui
ont des des des des ministères décisifs
et je pense que serait très intéressant
de montrer que dans ce domaine aussi il
y a des progrès à faire ce qui si j'ai
compris le test de votre donc je suis
preneur de de donnez-moi ça monsieur
Nère a parlé des efforts de pédagogie et
tout à fait raison et là euh nous
n'avons pas encore suffisamment avancé
nous n'avons pas pu euh parce qu' des
travaux à faire des slogans enfin des
exemples simples c'est c'est B àas mais
nous allons nous y mettre maintenant la
même façon que les transport il connaî
ça très bien il sait aussi que en tant
qu'ancien président de l'agglomération
ranaise c'est un sujet que je connais
assez bien et sur l'électrique et donc
si on peut faire avancer les choses
excellent euh la question sociale oui il
faut non pas que qui dit social dit
comment direrib ibution préférentielle
au syndicat mais il faut que nous
mettons toutes les forces y compris les
forces syndicales dans le coup elles
sont demandresse d'ailleurs il faut le
faire non seulement au niveau européen
mais au niveau mondial Australie
Canada disons que en ce qui concerne
leur enthousiasme
écologique comment dire il y a encore
des marges de
progression l'Australie a changé de
gouvernement il y a quelques temps et le
nouveau Premier ministre conservateur a
fait campagne contre euh taxe carbone et
cetera euh au Canada il n'y a pas eu de
changement mais c'est une position
constante donc voilà vous savez sûrement
que l'Australie a la présidence du G20
là et nous avons demandé qu'elle
inscrivve à l'ordre du jour ce qui n pas
absolument spontané la question
climatique et auprès du Canada nous
allons devoir aussi faire effort nous
serons pas seuls si les Américains
bougent entraîna quand même probablement
aussi les Canadiens mais disons que ça
fait pas paraît ça fait partie dans
notre comment dire
planisphère politique des pays qui
restent à convaincre pour employer une
formule neutre les médias bon je
rappellerai cette anecdote que j'avais
beaucoup aimé dans un livre du président
Pompidou consacré à sa vie enfin livre
de mémoire que j'avais lu un jour comme
ça et il avait dit quelque chose donc
c'était dans les années Pidou c'était 70
qui n'a pas vieilli d'une ride il
raconte l'histoire suivante
euh madame Pompidou va inaugurer un
hôpital en Bretagne je crois à l'époque
il y avait encore l' RTF bon et le la
station locale
de l'ORTF envoie à l'époque il y avait
des télégrames je crois télégram au
siège de l'ORTF faut-il filmer madame
Pompidou et la réponse c'est filmer si
incident bon tout est dit tout est dit
voilà n pas nous som pas pris une ride
bon donc ce que vous avez dit tel à côté
plus intéressant que
hein que que que tel axe central bon
alors nons pas contrôler médias ça n'a
aucun sens donc il faut que que les
choses soient organisées de manière
telle que comment dire même les aspects
majoritaires soient
intéressants pas obligé d'aller sur le
petit côté des choses mais ça demande
beaucoup de réflexion beaucoup de
techniqu et donc il faut bien sûr si
nous voulons contribuer à la réussite
que cet aspect là soit aussi prise en
compte sans avoir en quoi que ce soit
l'illusion de contrôler les choses il n
pas question mais au moins donner aux
médias qui veulent faire objectivement
leur travail les occasion de le faire je
termine madame joanau donc qui était à
Copenhague si je comprends bien donc son
expérience est très utile je vous ai dit
un mot sur europeafrique là c'est
quelque chose sur quoi il faut que nous
nous appuyons Brésil bon il se trouve
que mon nouveau collègue ministre d'
affaires étrangères est le négociateur
de rioo donc il connaît les choses
beaucoup beaucoup mieux que moi et ça se
voit quand je discute avec lui euh et
euh bon le Brésil a une position très
forte euh dans ce genre de conférence et
en même temps parfois un peu difficile à
cerner bon et donc euh nous allons faire
le maximum pour que le Brésil soit du
côté de la réussite voilà l'objectif que
nous pouvons essayer de euh nous fixer
région oui les régions quand je disais
collectivités local c'était les communes
les régions et cetera et nous allons
avoir
euh est-ce que c'est cette année bon euh
en octobre il y a une espèce de de grand
réunion des régions où nous aurons le
plaisir d'accueillir monsieur schwar
seneger qui doit présider d'ailleurs ce
rassemblement puisque il a été je crois
qu'il n'est plus mais gouverneur en
Californie et
euh mais il faut faire flèche de tout
bois hein euh mais je compte beaucoup
sur les régions parce que souvent ce
sont elles qui sont le plus engagé
l'idée c'est que collectivités diverses
communes départements région et cetera
tout le monde montre que il y a des
résultats positif lycée AF oui vous avez
tout à fait raison d'ailleurs j'ai
demandé à
Madame farnaau La la la patronne de la
EFE de de et elle le fait elle m'a dit
que ça ça prenait très bien de de mettre
ses thématique à l'ordre du jour dans
les différents lycées bon ça intéresse
beaucoup et du coup ça peut diffuser
dans les familles auprès de différents
milieux dernier point
conyegard et le traité transatlantique
bon conygard est une fille femme très
compétente malheureusement son mandat à
la Commission va terminer va se terminer
je sais pas par qui elle va être
remplacée ce sera important parce que le
rôle du commissaire est
important mais comme elle connaît le
sujet admirablement elle en connaît
aussi les difficultés non seulement au
niveau européen mais au niveau mondial
simplement elle bon elle mettra son
énergie au au service d'un succès
possible mais
a raison de dire que le succès n'est pas
assuré le traité transattique bon c'est
un autre sujet
euh dont dont vous aurez à
débattre par mis bon le le traité
transatlantique je voyais des articles
de journaux aujourd'hui et puis à
l'approche des élections européennes
j'ai l'impression que on peut faire des
rapprochements qui d'ailleurs ne sont
pas illégitimes et tel ou tel parti
prend position plutôt contre que pour je
pas beaucoup recensé de parti qui disent
oui quoi qu'il en soit moi j'ai vu ce
matin c'est le hasard des choses le
négociateur américain qui est à Paris et
je lui dis ceci que je vous redis
écoutez cher Monsieur euh nous nous
abordons ça sans préjuger bon quels sont
les objectifs les objectifs c'est si
possible pour l'Europe et pour la France
d'avoir un marché plus important de
faire en sorte que nous que nous
puissions vendre davantage de produits
agricoles davantage d'Appellation
d'Origine contrôlé que nous puissions
pénétrer davantage au marchés publics
euh deux chiffres je sais pas s sont
exactes c'est ceux qui figurent dans les
rapports nous nos marchés publics
européens sont ouverts à 85 % euh les
marchés pu américain avec les régions
fédération à 20 % bon donc évidemment si
nous pouvions pénétrer ces marchés très
intéressant pour nous ça c'est les
objectifs les risques les risques c'est
que ça se passe pas du tout comme ça les
risques c'est que alors que les
Américains ont accepté que l'audiovisuel
et ceeta soit en dehors à un moment ils
nous disent non les risques c'est que
les préférence collective que nous
voulons maintenir est un mot prétencieux
pour dire que nous voulons un poulet qui
soit soit pas frelaté nous voulons
laaffaire des EGM et cetera ne soit pas
respecté le risque c'est que sur les
marchés publics les États fédérés nous
dis ah bah écoutez on est désolé ça vous
avez discuté avec le centre mais vous
avez pas discuté avec nous et nous on
n'est pas d'accord donc il y a la fois
des perspectives il y a des risques il y
a un problème c'est celui auquel vous
avez fait allusion c'est quelle est
l'instance d'appel qui n'est pas encore
décidé il faut choisir une instance qui
ne soit enfin qui soit objective et qui
nous mette pas dans difficulté et il y a
un autre aspect qui est bon on comprend
bien que certains aspects de la
négociation puissent être secret mais
moi j'ai dit et je l'ai dit ce matin ou
non j'ai pas dit cet après-midi à
l'Assemblée mais ce matin dans groupe
dans lequel je participais le
gouvernement viendra tous les 3 mois
devant l'Assemblée devant le Sénat pour
dire voilà où nous en sommes puisque de
toutes les manières le négociateur
européen il y a une négociation tous les
3 mois bon s'il y a des choses secrètes
ben voilà on dira c'est secret mais sur
l'essentiel de la négociation je vois
pas pourquoi on ne dirait pas ce ce qui
se passe étanté qu'à la fin il faudra
quand même que vous disiez oui ou disiez
non bon moi je je pars je pars pas avec
une idée préconçue si les objectifs
peut-être atteints que les risques sont
écartés bravo si les objectifs ne
peuvent pas être atteint et que les
risques au contraire adviennent ce sera
non bon et on ne parle pas en disant oh
c'est merveilleux parce que c'est
américains ou oh c'est horrible parce
que c'est américains je pense qu'il faut
être très comment dire en mon français
matofac on va regarder honnêtement bon
j'ai discuté mais c'était trop rapide
avec le négociateur américain puis
j'avais vu toute une série de notes au
stade où j'en suis je suis incapable de
vous dire si finalement ce sera oui ou
ce sera non je ne sais pas mais ça
dépend de la négociation ellemême sur le
calendrier ce que m'a dit le négociateur
c'est que il y a des élections de moyen
terme aux États-Unis à la fin de l'année
donc il est pas question qu'il y ait des
avancées significatives avant bon donc
si on peut avancer ce sera l'année
prochaine d'près ce que j'ai compris euh
bon eux souhaitent avancer mais ça
dépendra vraiment du contenu de la
négociation bon et je trouve par rapport
à telle ou telle position que je vois
autant dire quoi qu'il arrive ce sera
oui ça n'a pas de sens ça dépend du
contenu autant dire quoi qu'il arrive ce
sera non alors que les
États-Unis et et l'Europe ça fait quand
même quoi 40 % du commerce mondial donc
si on pouvait aller en avant et aller
chercher des points de croissance
pourquoi pas mais au stade où nous en
sommes je suis je je pense qu'il n'est
vraiment pas possible de dire voilà
quelle va être la sanction finale
sachant que la sanction finale même si
c'est un négociateur européen qui
discute il faut que nous soyons d'accord
à la fin donc nous pouvons dire oui ou
nous pouvons dire non voilà où nous en
sommes bien excusez-moi peut-être
d'avoir été trop court dans mes réponses
mais merci à vous c'est nous qui vous
remercions Monsieur
Merci voilà pour cette audition de
Laurent Fabius le ministre des Affaires
étrangères qui avait été auditionné par
les commissions du développement durable
et des affaires économiques du Sénat
afin d'expliquer les enjeux pour le
gouvernement de la préparation de la
conférence sur le climat de Paris en
2015 vous pouvez toujours voir et revoir
toutes les auditions sur notre site
publsenat.fr très bonne journée sur les
chaînes
parlementaire